hey guys how's it going it's Justine
today I am joined with my two sisters
this is Jenna and this is Brianne I hear
all about being on a YouTube video you
got me here because of Oreos so we're
gonna do a taste test of the new pumpkin
spice Oreos I'm pretty sure these have
probably been out before I don't really
know I saw them on Amazon and I was like
buy it now the Brianne absolutely loves
Oreo these do and she doesn't like
pumpkin yet do not so this is a problem
have you had these before
wait world a regular you promise your
regular you do must be regular he
surprised I get ready to be here
consolation prize these are mine I with
this whole entire thing
stuff it doesn't f no I'm over here I'm
over here on this side no break your
elbow no you did three of them that's
what happened be smelling good baby
smell Jagger it's like baked pumpkin
yeah which is even the worst pumpkin all
right it'll taste it taste it up right
good you like it huh doctor not Maddie's
really vanilla cinnamon yeah and I like
some nutmeg taste
no no nutmeg cinnamon no what do you
think I'll be Oreo do you like it I like
it it's like a cinnamon need it's
cinnamon for someone but not really good
the doesn't like pumpkin she likes it
did you try it
she's got these for a couple days here
and she keeps saying don't eat the Oreos
wouldn't let us see the Oreo but you
also have something else
these are pumpkin JoJo's and I would say
that this is a taste test like I've
never tried them before but if you want
to talk about self-control give it this
felt more like real pumpkin you know
like real pump these are a little
something here soggy you know it's funny
cuz Brian just had one he said I think
these are stale man we didn't close the
box I'm cold walk to this can't be a
true taste City fair wanna eat the whole
world the other day I really enjoyed
them better than the for you I don't
know that was really good this is really
I was really good I think I like the
volume this is definitely sale
guess what Brian said yeah I made a
mistake I left this open for like three
days fresh today that's not a comparison
these are Jojo they're Halloween cookies
like pumpkin pumpkin fate all the
pumpkin faced with vanilla bean cream so
so this should be good against the Oreo
oh I like these at all steaks too
healthy
just criticize Trader Joe's on it she
thinks it's healthy no this tastes like
vitamins there's six percent iron in
here like it's a pumpkin pie you gotta
still you got a quadruple
nothing what that's disgusting my phone
you need auro
it's the only way to eat I mean I am
grossly not make up stuff like the mega
stuff is already stopped mm-hmm this is
good always do for I think I like this
one better than I like their original
here so go eat some water
send me my video my Luckies a lot more
[__] stale about them at the CBS
they're fired by October 11 2007 team
funds only few days my submit over
though
Wow left can you believe that was
expired new arch blur I was like that's
weird because they definitely tasted
rock just nicely it's nice
Oh what is this expire like absolute
I'll try it
makeup no that's enough with the accent
is very stable drag at the vacuum where
are these knives coming from I don't
feel safe you should be honest with you
that's a little wobbly
wall and I'm in the picture oh god
lookit I found taste what is this huh
mega trash the mega stuff we're
definitely rotten
I'm so sorry Bri I was so excited about
this and I didn't think to look at the
expiration date today when I got them
for you this dates good this is like a
nice cinnamon Oreo I really really like
this one I actually it was good cinnamon
oh hi picture yogi the pumpkin spice is
made of like nutmeg and some nutmeg is
that the only spice you know no but I
just made a pumpkin pie I mean nutmeg oh
wait did you make a pumpkin pie or did
you try to make an apple pie
oh I got confused about how to make a
pie and a lot of things happen but you
guys will see that they make it work
alright guys well thanks for watching um
thanks for being in my video pretty it
took me a lot of time to try to drag her
over here to be in my video it's true
and all I got idea was I'm a lady
and I said okay I don't have anything
for you to be in my video they don't get
your fresh we'll skittle oh you're gonna
just I'll get you a script universal
alright guys thanks for watching happy
is not Halloween yet happy almost
Halloween happy Halloween seize the
season for season of the ween pumpkins
okay I'm not a we you later
look I see them we nice he's lonely we
need to do another vacuum
I'm super impressed another one
yeah Yoshi Jenna's video now drinking
coffee with that one you can go ahead
and coffee [__] already
[Music]
[Applause]